the jurogan experience so tell me first
of all tell me what was the
inspiration to start sub stack like how
did it how did it come about
i've always been an avid reader
my dad was an english teacher growing up
we had books around the house and i've
always thought that
what you read
matters like it shapes who you are it
shapes how you think it creates like who
you are as a person
and so great
writing matters a lot
right i must i in my other life i do
software
software is this magical thing where you
can run write a piece of code
and it does something for a million
people if you write a great essay a
great book a great thought you can
change who a million people are and so
great writing is this valuable thing
and
when i took a sabbatical from a company
that i'd done i was like i should be a
writer that would be good like how hard
could it be
these guys are doing doing good things i
started writing what i thought was going
to be like an essay or a blog post or a
screed or something
outlining my frustration with
the state of the media industry the
state of incentives on the internet
basically complaining
social media is breaking our brains you
know this kind of [ __ ]
and i send it to my friend hamish who's
really a writer and
he told me
like anybody can complain about this
stuff you're not as original as you
think all of my friends who are writers
know all of this stuff
the more interesting question is
if all of this is true
what could you do about it
and that
be that
turned into substance and what year was
this 2017
it's really perfect timing
for when everything started getting
really heavy in terms of censorship and
also the the chaos that came about
because the pandemic and journalists
getting cancelled and
there was so much weird stuff in terms
of what you're allowed to write about or
not allowed to write about
and then of course the hunter biden
thing the laptop like all that stuff
like came about in the first few years a
lot of the best writers in the world in
my estimation were getting kind of
tissue rejected from the places where
they would have
been before tissue rejected like
isn't it
an analogy like they're getting like an
organ transplant that fails kind of
thing they're getting sort of pushed out
from the the places that would have been
their home and where they could have
done the thing that that mattered to
them before
what happened how did how do you think
that like what steps
fell into place that caused all this
my theory on this is that it's a
combination of
natural
human
affairs right like there's human nature
people act in certain ways there's dark
tendencies that come out when you get
people together at scale
colliding with
the consequences of the first generation
of the internet revolution basically the
way that the first generation of the
internet played out was this massive
land grab for human attention so first
of all the computer and then even more
so the smartphone kind of gobbled up
all of the slices of people's lives that
were just sitting there people used to
get bored
and then the smartphone came along and
that just didn't exist anymore and in
that phase the things that won were the
things that were the most efficient at
gobbling up everyone's attention
and so you had this sort of the game
that everyone played was like get
everyone's eyeballs and the things that
you do to to win at that game create an
incentive landscape that drives everyone
crazy
yeah the the way to win at that game is
be outraged or get people outraged yeah
the way to win a twitter is be bad in a
lot of ways and if you don't want to do
it somebody else will be bad
well i mean bad in some like be
outrageous be
the the ultimate tweet as i've found out
myself sometimes is not the thing that
everyone agrees with or even the thing
that everyone hates is the thing that
maximally divides people the thing that
most separates the people that are in
your tribe on your side and makes them
kind of like cheer
and at the same time spits in the face
of of the other people that is the the
recipe for a successful
tweet because
that's the incentive landscape that
makes twitter succeed
yeah it's just i go on twitter once a
day maybe twice a day just to see what
kind of [ __ ] the monkeys are throwing at
each other
that's it seems like a like a mental
institution sometimes i see people
arguing over things and things that are
trending that have zero impact in my
life and i don't understand why people
are putting so much attention to it but
it seems like
the recreational outrage that comes
about
because of twitter is one of the most
addictive things i've ever witnessed
people take part in i mean i say people
i've i took part in it a little bit for
a while but now i don't engage at all i
literally i don't read my mentions i
occasionally post things then i just get
the [ __ ] out of there i i just think
it's too
it's just too
poisoned yeah
you're a wiser man than most
well i just see it i see it in other
people i see what it does to people you
know i it's just
it's very strange because i never
thought twitter was going to become that
i always thought twitter was just like
some innocuous thing when it first came
around it was silly a lot of comedians
loved it because it was a great little
uh
because in the beginning it was only 140
characters it's great to keep your jokes
succinct in little short little blurbs
and try to fun find fun funny things to
say
but then it just became
some strange way for people to expose
their mental illness
yeah and none of that stuff is new none
of the bad things that people do on
social media are
a new facet of humanity it's just it
amplifies it and it creates this like
false reality that everyone sees that
slowly drives us crazy so how difficult
was it to a start sub stack and then b
get journalists to come on board
the hardest part of starting substack
was
convincing ourselves that it could work
because it started as i was literally
writing this essay and hamish and i were
talking and we just came across this
idea of like what if we let
writers go independent themselves what
if we let you start your own thing you
get the email addresses you own
everything people can pay you directly
now you're getting hired and fired by
your readers it's the super it sounded
too simple to possibly work where like
if this thing could work somebody would
have done this already it seems stupid
but we kind of talked each other into it
and you know i'm a tech nerd i'm a
product guy hamish is not that he's a
writer he knows that world
and we kind of both thought that it
could work
and so we just sort of like slowly
talked each other into it he had a
friend who was a writer who like needed
it right away basically
had wanted something like this and
became our first customer
a guy called bill bishop writes cynicism
it's a newsletter about china that
everybody in business government reads
why did he need it right away well he i
mean he so he had this newsletter that
he'd been writing for free and paying
for the privilege of sending that was
just like what the hell is actually
going on in china for anybody who needs
to actually know
and you know lots of business people
government people all over the world
would read it and he's like i should
charge instead of paying to send this
thing out i should charge people for
this obviously
but
i couldn't figure out how to get the you
know wire up the payment with the
sending and the like he just needed
someone to handle
the details of it and we were like great
we'll do that for you we'll we'll do
everything for you except the hard part
and then so you got him
and how did you get the word out like
how did it how did it start to really
become a player
a lot of it was we started with hamish's
friends like people who who he knew
and we would just go and talk to them
and especially early on a lot of it was
just telling people about this why we
were doing this thing and what we
thought was wrong
and how this fairly simple
platform we were building could help and
if people
bought this like believed in the things
we were saying
then they would think oh maybe i'll try
this
and it really started with just great
writers that hamish knew or that people
that we brought on knew and we just were
like
here's what we're doing and why
do you guys get resistance because i
know there were some people that were
writing bad things about sub stack or
saying that the sub stack is a bad idea
what was the argument
there's been a there's been a few i mean
one that comes up a lot is
there's been a few generations of it at
the very start you're asking how we
started the argument was like no one's
going to pay for anything you idiots
right right it's like you know writers
on the internet social media is bad yeah
all sounds good theoretically but i'm
never going to pay for anything never
going to work good luck
and
i had this parlor trick where i'd run on
people i just was like well who's your
favorite writer
after they just told me they would never
pay for a writer in their like who's
your favorite writer they'd say uh so
and so i'd be like would you pay five
bucks a month to like get their stuff
directly
and they'd be like yeah i probably would
but that's different it's that person
it's this thing and so we sort of there
was this weird thing where nobody
thought it would work in the abstract
but it worked once you had something
that you cared about
um so we kind of crossed the like it's
never gonna work thing and then
immediately got into the it's working
and it's bad time
for a bunch for a bunch of things uh
probably the most prominent of which is
we started with this really strong
commitment to free speech if we think
that we're making a platform for writers
that is
you know can can be a positive force in
our intellectual climate
we just think that's table stakes that's
something that's an important principle
and we came up in a time that not
everyone believes in that at all
we took a lot of [ __ ] for a bunch a
bunch of different times for
well why do you let this person send
emails to people that want to get it
from them like specifically like can you
say like what writers were problematic
would you like to avoid that um we could
avoid that i don't want to put anyone on
a block let's just talk about like
subjects like what would you do like
here's a question what if you had i mean
i think the sub stack is like how many
how many people do you have on it right
now
how many people in terms of writers
how many people there's like tens of
thousands wow
pretty cool
it's going yeah it's wild that happened
so quickly um what have you got it's
like a holocaust denier starts
publishing stuff on substance
we so we have uh
terms of service that we set out that
has a couple of like really strict
really uh tightly construed things most
of it's like you can't spam you can't do
these things um we do i mean we do have
a couple things like there's no porn um
you're not allowed to like advocate for
literal violence uh there's a few things
that that are sort of just like bright
lines that are intended to be
kind of like a really high bar
and allow for space where there's a lot
of [ __ ] on substance that we
ourselves disagree with and find awful
we try to take you know we think that
kind of the old school aclu approach on
this is correct right where they're
protesting to like help the nazis have
their free speech rights right um not
because we think those things are good
but because we think that airing them
is more valuable and in the long run
better than trying to solve the problem
i sense right now so there are people
that are on substance that
everybody sort of agrees or gross
i mean i don't know if there's anybody
that everybody agrees or gross but for
you guys for any individual i think
anybody
that exists could find someone on sub
stack that they think is the greatest
thing ever and they can find someone on
a subset they think is terrible and we
take that as a sign that we're doing it
right
so
no porn what what are the other ones
i'd have to look it up it's like
yeah no i think there's a doxing thing
there's like a advocating violence
there's a few like kind of
things that just break the edges do you
allow erotica like if someone published
like bigfoot porn yeah we can't read
those our our genius our genius take on
this is that we disallow porn but we
allow erotica and it turns out that's
like a
that's a non-trivial thing but the
intention is like look there's already
only fans if you're just doing
that right there's a place for you
um and we're not this this you know i
don't even think i don't have a problem
with i don't think that's wrong but
that's just not the the
thing that we're trying to serve